صراخ وبكاء يتعاليان وسط الركام تكسرهما
احيانا فرحه بنجاه من كابوس احد اقوى
الزلازل في تاريخ تركيا وسوريا معا مشاهد
لخصت يوما حزينا في البلدين مئات القتلى
والاف الجرحى والحصيله مرشحه للارتفاع مع
وجود الاف المحاصرين تحت الانقاض لكن وسط
حاله الحزن هذه قد تتراءى بريقه امل بصرخه
نجاه احدهم رجال الانقاذ يسابقون الزمن
لاخراج اجساد كتبت لاصحابها اعمار جديده
طفله صغيره ابت الا ان تهزم رجات الزلزال
وظلت صامده حتى انتشلتها فرق الانقاذ
حفره صغيره قد تتحول الى بوابه امل كبيره
بالنسبه لاطفال النجو باعجوبه من الموت
ومحظوظ من وجد طفله حيا وسط الركام فهناك
ما لا يزال ينتظر معرفه مصير ذويه وبينما
هناك من علق تحت الارض اخرون علقوا في
مرتفعات البنايات نزولهم الى الارض هذه
المره كان مختلفا الى درجه الدخول في نوبه
هستيريه من البكاء بالفرحه والصدمه مع ماء
الارقاد والطقس البارد تكالبت على
العالقين الذين لم يجدوا سوى الاغطيه
لتحدي يوم مزلزل اما هذا الطفل فقد اختار
الابتسامه سلاحا لمواجهه حزنه على ما
اتلفته الهزات من اغراض شخصيه
وسام الذهبي العربي